comme dans un roman d'aventurés
étonnante opération de commando des
israéliens sur l'aéroport d'entebbe en
ouganda la nuit dernière sur cet
aéroport hier soir sans cinq otages
équipage d'air france inclus attendre
que soit négocier leur libération
négociée avec le commando pro
palestiniens qui a détourné il ya une
semaine
l'airbus d'air france à bord duquel il
voyageait pour une fois
dérogeant à ses habitudes de fermeté
l'état d'israël semble prêt à composer
c'est à dire à libérer ou à faire
libérer par les états occidentaux qui
les détiennent 52 prisonniers pro
palestiniens israël semble vouloir
composer car autour de minuit quand se
pose sur l'aéroport den tb trois
appareils militaires venus tel aviv
ils ne transportent pas les 52
prisonniers qui auraient pu servir de
donner des changes à bord de ses
appareils qui ont fait escale au kenya
pour se ravitailler des fantassins et
des parachutistes israéliens
bref bataille brève mais c'est vers
l'armée ougandaise dont le rôle actif
aux côtés des ravisseurs semblent
maintenant établie
l'armée ougandaise s'en mêle elle va
perdre une centaine d'hommes dans la
bataille
six ou huit chasseurs à réaction
l'aéroport d'un bébé va être totalement
détruit si l'on en croit le chef suprême
de l'ouganda maréchal idi amin dada
vingt hommes du côté ougandais perdront
la vie à la suite de cette opération
si on écoute les à seilh aux israéliens
cette opération va coûter la vie de
trois des otages et d'un des officiers
du commando spécial
il y aura encore 11 blessés parmi les
passagers de l'airbus
l'appareil resté à l'écart sur la piste
c'est à ce prix que le coup de main et
conduit à bien c'est sans précédent à
3800 km des bases de l'armée israélienne
les ravisseurs palestiniens sont tués il
n'y a plus d'eau tard à entebbe tous
sont rapatriés sur tel aviv surprise
audace efficacité les trois conditions
de cette réussite de cette opération
menée dans le secret le plus total
ce n'est qu'après coup que paris a été
prévenu sans doute pour que le
gouvernement français ne soient pas
gênés diplomatiquement paris pour
l'instant ne réagit que par une courte
déclaration d'un porte-parole du
ministère des affaires étrangères les
autorités françaises expriment leur
satisfaction à la suite de la libération
des 102 otages et leur sympathie à
l'égard des familles des tués et des
blessés
pour israël l'opération s'inscrit dans
une attitude de vigilance permanente le
premier ministre itzhak rabin vient de
dire que l'opération d'un bébé
s'inscrira certainement dans l'histoire
militaire
la légende et la tradition nationale 10
heures ce matin le premier des c-130 qui
a participé à l'opération dans tb se
pose alors à son bord des otages libérés
départ et israéliens et l'équipage d'air
france
les deux autres avions c130 atterriront
dans l'après midi une foule énorme a
envahi l'aéroport à tel point que les
officiels chargés d'accueillir les
otages ne pourrons arriver jusqu'à la
foule est en liesse
cris de joie applaudissements ont on en
entendra aussi la sonnerie du chauffard
la corne de bélier qui retentit aux
fêtes et aux prières cris de joie et
larmes d'émotion lorsque les familles se
reprit une femme dira jamais aucun
d'entre nous n'aurait osé espérer que
nos soldats
réussir est une opération aussi
dangereuse on soulignera aussi le
courage et l'aide de l'équipage d'air
france restait avec les hôtes à côté
official shimon peres ministre israélien
de la défense dira que je jouerai
considéré par israël comme une fête
nationale enthousiasme partagé par
l'ambassadeur de france à jérusalem
la force brutale mais gagner qu'en plus
on ne gagne pas c'est une satisfaction
sur le plan de la morale et je pense que
nous sommes ici en touche
prodigieusement amiral 10 pour la
passionnante et du rouge cette opération
pour les israéliens l'opération dans tb
et la contribution d'israël dans la
lutte mondiale contre le terrorisme ne
pouvait en être autrement a qui n'en
tenait le porte parole de l'ambassade
d'israël il ne fallait en aucun cas
permettre un succès de ce terrorisme
succès du chantage qui deviendrait de
plus en plus grand de plus en plus
important de surcroît il y avait là un
cas où un chef d'état en l'occurrence
idi amin a collaboré avec les
terroristes et a donné son soutien
matériel et moral et c'est une chose qui
est contraire à la loi internationale et
à la civilisation
donc nous n'avions pas d'autre choix
dans cette affaire comment jouer les
relations franco israéliennes
non cette bataille ne fait elle y est
voilà c'est hong kong australienne
savait pas partie de l'ensemble des
relations franco israéliennes mais
parlons de cet épisode d'une façon
précise la coordination la collaboration
pas de ce qui est arrivé hier soir me
jusque-là entre israël et la france au
départ fait la correction des autorités
françaises qui sont farine est ce que
vous voulez dire que le gouvernement
français n'a pas été a été ou n'a pas
été prévenu des mesures qui allaient
prendre le gouvernement israélien des
mesures dès hier soir certainement pas